let's talk about stubborn fat you can
diet and exercise but still have issues
with your love handles
and muffin top well our next guest has a
non-surgical
solution welcome back brittany from the
jazzy wellness brittany it's great to
see you
tell everyone what body contouring is
and how does it work
so it's a non-surgical non-invasive way
to permanently kill fat
and tighten the skin simultaneously i
love the key word there non-surgical
how many sessions are needed until we
start seeing results
on session one typically we'll see two
to three inches but we've seen people
lose up to seven
and this is for both men and women and
what are we looking at right here the
actual process works
yes so that is the portion that
permanently kills the fat using heat and
sound technology
i'm sorry i gotta go back to something
you just said did you say you can lose
one inch in your first session
two to three two three inches this is
incredible so how long does a session
last
about an hour and then how long do these
results
look at these before and after photos by
the way that is
unbelievable how the results how long do
they last
they're permanent the fat that we kill
is permanently dead the skin that we
tighten will hold as long as your skin
holds its laxity so that we can't stop
the aging process but we can run it back
a little bit
so talk about the process so again
someone's watching this right now they
want to come in and have things done
what's the process is there a
consultation
how does it work so we'll do a free
consultation
you'll show us the area that you want to
address we'll recommend how many
sessions we think you'll need
typically we'll do a package of four or
six
and then we'll get started and you'll
start losing inches
it's incredible results the pictures
speak for themselves you always have a
special what kind of special do you have
for us today
so the first 10 callers will get a free
consultation and 40
off beautiful thank you so much brittany
for joining the show we appreciate it
and for jazzy wellness they're located
at 900 south valley view boulevard sweet
100
you can find them online at
thejazzywellness.com and take advantage
of this special deal
guaranteed lose two inches same day
first 10 callers get 40
off a series of body contouring call
them today at
zero
702-800-7406